so far Anheuser-Busch has lost around 5
billion dollars in market cap because of
the controversy with their sponsorship
of transgender influencer Dylan Mulvaney
and there's a lot of conversations still
emerging around it I think Joe Rogan had
a conversation on one of his episodes
where he's like oh it's no big deal or
something like that I'm like ah it's
over Howard Stern talked about it I just
don't understand why people are so upset
and I find it fascinating that there is
this massive backlash which has
persisted into this week over the
holiday weekend and anheuser-busch's
stock has still been in Decline and
there are people coming up being like no
everything's fine everything's okay and
I can only respond to that by over
Target and I'll stress this point again
if Anheuser-Busch is forced to issue an
apology it will be a major shift in the
culture War because that will be the
point when a major multinational brand
is forced to say the conservatives the
Libertarians the freedom faction they
were all right about this that means
they are more scared of you saying I
won't buy your product than of the far
left extremists in their campaign and
there's some new information emerging
about the VP which proves in my opinion
this is all an ideological push a viral
video came out where the VP their new VP
of marketing whatever said that it's a
dying brand and we've got to inject some
life into it that's strange the brand
itself but light was the highest selling
beer of last year and more importantly
photos have leaked of this VP having
herself a frat party and what was she
doing blowing up condoms or something or
drinking shots out of them taking well
there you go so this idea of inclusivity
or whatever it is she's talking about
clearly isn't a part of her life clearly
doesn't matter to the stronger brand
when Anheuser-Busch is seeing record
profits Bud Light selling them most out
of any beer bread in the world and then
they claim it's dying so we have to
change it you know they're lying so
we're going to talk about all of that
stuff especially with what's been
happening with regional Distributors and
then there actually is probably bigger
news but it's political
and we've talked about it quite a bit
there's a whistleblower who's come out
and said that he can put him put him in
front of a grand jury and he will say
under oath that Joe Biden committed
crimes promoting barisma helping his son
in his private business dealings in
Ukraine and I think that's particularly
important however we're not in a
political electoral cycle I think the
Anheuser-Busch battle may be one of the
most important culture War battles we're
seeing right now and then of course NPR
and I think PBS just announced this too
they're quitting Twitter because Elon
Musk correctly labeled them
state-affiliated and government funded
on they're crying about it it's all true
by the way they are before we get
started my friends head over to
castbrew.com and pre-order your cast
Brew Coffee that's right today's episode
is brought to you by casparu coffee the
coffee company that we have launched as
part of our new coffee shop which will
be opening hopefully in the next few
months you can pick up your rise with
Roberto Jr breakfast Blend or your
Appalachian nights and these will ship
by May 5th so it's just entering
production in the past few weeks and
then will ship by then also don't forget
to head over to timcast.com click join
us to become a member and support our
work and as a member you'll get access
to uncensored segments from this show
Monday through Thursday at 11 PM
we'll have one of those up for you
tonight and if you're a member for at
least six months or you set up the 25
level you can actually get access to our
Discord server which allows you to call
into the show and ask questions of us
and our audience so don't don't forget
to also smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
all of this and more is Jesse Kelly
Tim honored to be here it's uh going to
be a rambunctious night with all the Bud
Light news oh yeah particularly
interesting stuff so who are you what do
you do I am Jesse Kelly I am for one I'm
the menu Whisperer I'm the greatest
order of food in the world if you look
at a restaurant menu I just am a genius
when it comes to ordering those but I
also have a show naturally syndicated
radio show called The Jesse Kelly show I
have a TV show called I'm right and now
I'm a world famous author I wrote my
first book ever that doesn't come out
till June but I'm sure it'll be world
famous called the anti-communist
manifesto right on well thanks for
joining us of course and of course Luke
gradkowski's over here not paying
attention and posting memes or something
I'm working here okay the memes can't
post themselves right my name is Luke
kardaski here of weird change the dark
today I'm wearing a t-shirt that says
defund the ATF and make a storefront
which you could get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and the
Meetup is on for tomorrow 3 30 p.m
Austin Texas there's going to be some
surprise guests to find more about that
go to lucanfilter.com for more details
thanks for having me Jesse I'm going to
have to take you up on this menu claim
it's a bold statement the best of the
best look in God gives us all Talent
right you know Mozart could play
instruments or whatever he did when I
look at a menu I know the best thing to
order and people think I'm joking when I
say that but when we go out to dinner
which I'm sure we will at some point in
time you won't order what I order
because you don't trust me right now but
I will order something superior to yours
and you will look at my food and as
always happens you will say I should
have got what you got because you don't
trust you don't trust me but you will
eventually this excites me as you will I
love you Jesse thanks for coming bro
all right everybody let's jump into that
first story we got this one from the New
York Post Anheuser-Busch loses more than
five billion dollars in value amid Dylan
Mulvaney Bud Light controversy this
story is from just today so simply put
it's getting worse they say since March
31st shares of Bud Light its parent
company have fallen by nearly four
percent knocking down the company's
market capitalization from 132.38
billion to
127.13 billion on Wednesday
Anheuser-Busch stock fizzled more than
1.5 percent on Wednesday so let's talk
about this because uh just before the
show Ian brought up that uh Joe Rogan on
his show said it wasn't a big deal or
something to that effect could you uh
could you elaborate on that email yeah
and I don't want to put words in
anybody's mouth but it was uh a clip
that was on YouTube from and I should
pull this up immediately uh was it
recent or was it yeah it's very recent
he had a comedian on by the name of oh
come on but it usually takes a couple
days for him to release the podcast
though so that's also something we
should consider here but but Zachary the
one with Sam Talent uh Talent is like a
Sam Talent is a guy's name and really
Sam was talking about it when did it go
up it went up let's see six hours ago on
you so I imagine that was probably
recorded yesterday or Monday something
like that maybe yeah probably and I'll
say I think they're wrong about this
they crack a couple lights they're like
yeah I think the the drama's over and
but you were saying that you think maybe
he's there he's insulated being on
Spotify you guys were they were drinking
the beer yeah they pulled out a couple
Bud Lights
it kind of like tongue-in-cheek but the
same Talent is like yo I love Bud
light's great it's my favorite beer you
know how how could Bud Light be
someone's favorite beer I think he said
it was his favorite beer
you could drink 20 of them really you
can drink like six of them because
they're not really hot they're not
really thick it's the fluoride and the
cost of uh calcifying of the pineal
gland that gets people addicted towards
destroying their their frequencies right
it's the kind of beer yes yes but it's
the kind of beer you drink if you just
want to get drunk and you don't really
care about the flavor as the joke goes
it's the kind of beer you drink when you
don't want to drink beer but you want to
drink a lot of it I thought that I
didn't write that I saw that on on
Reddit or something I thought it was
brilliant but I heard that Joe Rogan
cracked open a beer and they're like ah
it's no big deal and it's like you know
what I wonder about this uh I wonder if
you know when Joe was on YouTube more on
YouTube he could more see the direct
impact of his comments and and what
people thought about them and when
you're on Spotify and you're releasing
you know after the fact I think the last
time I went on the show it was like five
days later they released it and I think
it was before I went on before the
writtenhouse verdict and then he aired
it after the writtenhouse verdict so
that like really changed a lot of the
context but I think what happens then is
if you're not really paying attention
you don't see what people are talking
about you're like I don't know I saw
some people talking about this kid rock
did a thing but I guess no one cares
anymore and now it's several days later
you put up an episode and once again
anheuser-bush stock is going down people
still care about this and the
conversation is persistent here's what I
think is happening a domino effect is
occurring where there was a major
backlash to the sponsorship of Dylan
Mulvaney this started a metaphorical
fire for Anheuser-Busch a bunch of
people then jumped on it started talking
about it which created an opportunity
for more commentators to say okay let's
talk about it I'll put it this way I'll
be completely blunt I didn't really care
all that much and then I saw the video I
did and I got 1.5 million views and that
said two things to me one people really
care about this and I think it's as
simple as you've screwed with their beer
and now they are pissed off the other
thing I realized is you are going to
start to see commentators capitalize on
that and they're going to make as much
content about it as possible because
people care which is for me let's be
honest a business opportunity but that's
ancillary more importantly it's a
culture War opportunity if this is the
Hill People are willing to die on let's
roll baby and now we have news coming
out leaks photos about the VP and about
her frat parties information is being
brought up about Bud Light sales it's
fair to say this is more than just Bud
Light this thing that happened last week
and no one cares anymore because Bud
Light has ignored their their their base
their Market
and they've they've basically doubled
down on this they've pissed people off
and they've created a viral opportunity
for online commentators be it for or
against it the fact that Joe Rogan
talked about it whatever it is he said
all that did was throw more fuel into
the fire it's going to get more people
asking what is going on with this NY
they actually talked about that on the
episode they were like look at us we're
drinking Bud Light right now so it's
working like any news is good news but I
it's not uh you can actually trash
people with a lot of news about them too
um well the issue is for Bud Light if
they're already at the top the top
selling beer in the world they can only
go down so that yes yes bat press is bad
for them and before the Scandal broke
out their stock was spiking up like 10
and now it's flip and started going down
where comparable beverage brands are not
seeing that same thing I actually I I
have a couple different things to say
about it I'm of two different Minds
about it one Bud Light and
Anheuser-Busch will be fine and they're
going to be fine for for a very specific
reason well two specific reasons one
because the right does cannot can never
maintain a culture War fight at all I I
I I know they had a bad bad weekend but
I watched the NFL have bad ratings for a
precisely about oh 15 minutes when black
lives matter was taken a steaming dump
all over the flag and every person on
the right they couldn't wait to run
social media and they're I'm done
forever and I'm done and NFL's racist
and I hate this place and I hate America
and like I said about 15 minutes later
they were all brag oh did you see that
throw from Drew Brees it was wonderful
the right can never maintain these
things because they don't love freedom
as much as the Communists hates Freedom
that's one agreed two but light
Anheuser-Busch is going to be fine
because the truth is as many
organization has found it has found out
from financial institutions to sports
like the NBA to others you do not need
to appeal to a customer base anymore
that is an old way of thinking you need
to appeal to the regime and right now we
have a new religion in America we are
the U.S of gay now that is the regime I
don't care what you think of it whatever
lgbtq whatever everything revolves
around that now we have the Secretary of
State saying he's riding Saudi Arabia
every single day about gay rights we we
are in a time of insanity in the United
States of America from the Pentagon to
the Secretary of State to entertainment
that's all they care about so if
Anheuser-Busch has proven they're going
to be loyal to the new religion of the
US of gay they will eventually be okay
they will disagree uh the point is
they've lost five billion dollars their
stock is going down and so long as
people have two things the willpower
which I admit is lacking among people
who are anti-establishment to a great
degree but there's something more
important here
you see outside of the willpower there's
monetary incentive so it may be that
many people on the right don't have the
willpower within 15 minutes would be
cheering for you know whoever's throwing
the latest touchdown pass the issue for
Budweiser right now they're not going to
be able to overcome is that online
personalities are getting a major flood
of viewership from talking about this
it's not going to go away so long as I
could put out a video and get half a
million views just by saying Budweiser
and that's an opportunity we've not seen
before so I don't care about the money I
care about the fact that people will
watch it and then I can say don't forget
don't buy Budweiser and it's not just
that we're not asking people to go out
and register a hundred thousand voters
we're not asking everybody right now to
be Scott Pressler we do wish everybody
would be Scott Pressler but if we can't
get that the least we can get is oh yeah
next time you go to the store
um my Guinness by by
I don't even know what PBR old style or
something let me tell you why I disagree
with that you're not wrong but I
disagree with it yes we can hurt them
and we should and we and I hope we
maintain this but really what what
drives so many of these corporations now
is the major financial institutions
including the financial institutions of
the United States States government all
of which now are governed by all this
ESG lgbtq all this insane crap so yeah
let's say Anheuser Bush let's say the
right finally steps up and sticks with
something and please Lord let them stick
with something for the first time ever
and let's say they stop buying in these
Southern Distributors really cancel
these orders and people stop buying and
they stick with them they don't forget
about this which they're gonna but let's
just say for the for the sake of
argument they do not you know what
Anheuser-Busch will still have access to
endless capital from Wall Street and
Washington DC because they have paid
homage to the religion of the nation
they've paid homage to America's
religion oh yes it should it means
everything why do you think the NBA has
taken the entire gen duration the entire
generation and they've alienated an
entire generation of American young
people because no reason to do that they
made a bet that conservatives classical
liberals will do nothing about it that
you're right about but this is where
we're starting to see something actually
bigger happen where people for the like
we look we've seen uh the Nike boycotts
right and the funny thing is when Colin
Kaepernick took a knee or whatever and
the Nike sponsors them all of these
videos emerge of people burning their
gear and their socks and all that within
three years every single athlete took a
knee and if you didn't you were the odd
person out that was a defeat something
different happens after a week and over
a holiday weekend when people are
supposed to forget about it
Anheuser-Busch thought they could keep
their mouths shut and this would go away
and we're looking at now a week of their
stock dropping I'll take it and I won't
shut up about it because if we can keep
the pressure on and keep talking about
it eventually get to the point where it
doesn't matter if they have endless
Capital if the regional if the regional
stores and the rural stores say we're
not going to carry your product it's
become popular and it's hurting our
brand to carry it because people are
getting offended are are angry that
we're not involved in this you're going
to see Distributors kicking it back
you're going to see people like John
Rich saying he won't carry the product
anymore but John Rich didn't say you
know what I hereby stand on principle
and will ban Anheuser-Busch uni said he
said honestly over the past week people
stopped buying it started to pile up so
we got we got to figure something out if
they're not going to buy it I'm not
going to I'm not gonna order it because
I'm losing money
John Rich came out after Kid Rock and
after uh Travis Tritt was just like hey
look nobody's buying it and if that's
what's really happening and we're seeing
videos of people in grocery stores
showing the Bud Light is all still there
and the Budweiser is also there and
other brands are gone and now we saw I
think even we saw Dan Crenshaw come out
and post a video about it earlier this
week more and more people are getting on
the meme and the trend of not drinking
Bud Light they're down I think four
points I mean that's massive imagine if
you invested in Anheuser-Busch and you
look after the past week and you and you
lost four percent imagine if you were a
billionaire and what four percent could
actually mean at this point I'm sure
there are people calling up Bud Light
and being like look I'm not going to
scream and throw a fit over four percent
this is probably going to be temporary
but you got to tell me what you're doing
about this and the pressure is starting
to build now we have another story let
me jump to this next story and uh and
talk to you about why I don't think this
is immediately going to be going away
we have the let me see if I can find
this one here we go we have this story
from the post to Millennial Bud light's
anti-frat marketing exec busted partying
frat style in leaked photos so
apparently someone had uh these photos
or whatever in an album for when they
were partying with this woman and they
showed that when she came out so let me
slow down and provide context for
everybody because we're entering a new
segment this VP came out amid the
controversy and said Bud Light was a
dying brand and we needed to make it
inclusive and get rid of that frat bro
image that's funny she is that fret bro
image she lived that life
and Bud Light is the number one selling
beer last year and the year before it
and so on and so forth so Bud light's
not a dying brand that it's absolutely
not true and this woman who claims she
wants to be inclusive and get away from
that frat bro culture is a part of that
culture now we've got a story piling on
she lied she lied she's an occult
ideologue who is exploiting this
position to take the top-selling beer in
the world and turn it into a woke woke
cult product to distribute a woke occult
product what they're really doing is
they're they're not worried about a
dying brand that's the LIE they're
taking over by infecting the largest
beer brand in the world and turning it
woke that's why I think if this
opportunity exists to to pounce on this
as they say and keep talking about it we
should but more importantly this story
about this woman shows the story's not
going away anytime soon the post
millennial ran the story I think New
York Post ran the story a bunch of news
outlets are going and the Daily Mail
they're they're saying this hey we're
making money covering this let's keep
doing it and that's the problem of the
internet age when people latch onto a
viral story and they won't let go it
won't stop no matter what you do it will
get crazier it will get worse and I am
hoping that the nightmare tornado of
viral memeology when someone comes to
hate something whips up into a frenzy to
the point where this VP is fired where
the marketing teams at Anheuser-Busch
are looking at a 10-point drop in their
stock when when when they're now
Fielding phone calls from their
investors being like why are we losing
this much money why isn't this going
away and they say
we're going to have to apologize and
when that happens what Anheuser-Busch
will signal to the entire world is we
screwed up we can't Embrace this
ideology we have lost too much money and
even if they could get loans it won't
matter if they can get endless ESG
Capital it won't matter because they'll
ship out products and the regional
stores will say I'm not going to carry
that my customers will Revolt I'll get a
bunch of people in front of my store
yelling at me get out of here and then
they cease to exist I don't think we're
anywhere near that it's one of the most
profitable beverage beverage companies
in the world with the top selling beer
but all we need is a couple a couple a
double digit percentage Point drop to
where Anheuser-Busch says clearly the
story won't go away and we've seen a
whole bunch of stories over the past few
years when people get obsessed with
something and refuse to let go and
you're wondering how is this story still
going viral how are they still talking
about it because we're going to keep
doing it because the people care about
it because the commentators make money
from doing it because the Tabloid media
makes money from doing it and the only
way out for Anheuser-Busch is an apology
I think the Daily Mail had a better more
accurate title for this particular story
they had rules for thee not for me Bud
Light exec demanding beer update it's
Friday image is seen partying at a 2006
Harvard Booze Fest and pounding shots
from condoms so uh yes that happened and
that's what everyone's talking about and
and to to go back to kind of Joe Rogan
here and to try to steal man his
argument I think what he's trying to say
is that he's maybe sick of cancel
culture he's maybe thinking that there
might be more important stories there
and I think on the other side
cancel culture has been weaponized I
think it's unavoidable and I think it's
at a point right now where sadly in the
culture War it is being used more and
more against individuals for doing less
and less things so to have a
counterbalance to it is I think what
you're arguing for Tim here and I'm
curious what the audience thinks do you
think that this is an issue that doesn't
really matter to you or do you think
that this is an issue that we must take
seriously in order to kind of hit back
against this larger culture War so I
don't know let's just see let's just see
the chat press number one if you think
that this is something that we should be
uh avoiding that there's bigger stories
there press number two if this is an
important issue to you that we should
take seriously I'm curious what people
say well my my view of it is
when when I heard that Joe Rogan cracked
open a Bud Light
the the most interesting reaction
actually was Howard Stern he didn't get
angry he didn't smack talk
he was he was confused I don't
understand is there something the story
that I'm missing there is but Kid Rock's
normal I'm sorry uh Howard Stern's
normal approach to culture War issues is
the right are a bunch of Nazi chuds
screw them etc etc when Kid Rock shot up
all that Bud Light and said Fu Howard
Stern didn't get mad all of a sudden he
said what's going on am I missing
something here that's actually what he
said am I missing some of this story and
he goes I've always been the you know
just you can be whatever you want to be
as long as you just don't hurt anybody
and therein lies the point what Dylan
Mulvaney is doing is hurting people it's
hurting children Tick Tock is promoting
an ideology that tells kids to harm
themselves and this is a fact what we
saw in Scandinavia was that child
medical transitions did not work and so
they abandoned it the Tavistock Center
uh clinic in the UK was shut down
because child sex changes were not
working but the United States is behind
the curve and they're still promoting
this and Tick Tock is promoting Dylan
Mulvaney to children
to then push this ideology on them
that's the issue with why it's bad that
Bud Light decided to sponsor Dylan
Mulvaney yeah Dylan just did a month ago
a video where he was dressed as a little
girl do singing a song from some musical
as a little piece or whatever yeah and
now they sponsored him for a beer
commercial but I think we're I think
we're almost saying two different things
now because I I'm not disagreeing with
verley anything you just said we should
press we should press I hope they drop I
hope that I I want it but boycott do all
that I'm I'm agreeing with you this is
insane we should do it what I'm saying
is a black pill though like there's no
way out there's no solution no that's
not what I'm saying there are solutions
but what I'm saying is that what this is
doing it won't be successful and let me
let me explain let's say Bud Light let's
say they do come out tomorrow and that
well back up we lost billions of dollars
hey guys put out a statement hey we're
sorry and no more of the dudes
pretending to be chicks on the beers
we're sorry sorry about that won't
happen again
now let's be honest here what's the
response to that the response to Bud
light's apology
is so much worse than anything the right
will be able to do to Bud Light with
sales when it comes to next two months
it would be that they'd have they'd have
actual violence because we all know
these commies come are violent that they
would they would have drivers being
assaulted that they would have mass
demonstrations every Tom Dick and
Harry's celebrity'd be on Instagram Bud
Light these Nazis that's the point they
can't afford to backtrack now because
they can't afford to offend the religion
of the state that is the one thing they
cannot afford to do and where you're
wrong is
if we get Budweiser to the point where
they apologize to us it means they fear
us more than them and they don't and
until we make them by their stock
dropping and their products not selling
and they realize their business can't
persist by offending their own audience
their own Market that means it has to be
sustained and persistent and it is the
easiest thing for anyone on the right to
do buy a different beer now that I agree
I look I agree this is the point I said
when Budweiser issues an apology to us
it means they are they are more scared
of losing their business from sales than
the violence of the left it is a fact
the the left uses violence to win the
culture War and the doj protects them
and the police protect them and if
anyone on the right so much as farts
they'll get arrested a guy can go to a
store in San Francisco with a garbage
bag and fill up product and they'll let
him go but if anyone dares try to stop
him they will get arrested Budweiser
knows that which means if it gets to the
point where their sales are gone because
we are their customers not so much me
but I mean it is regular
um like it it is not 22 year old college
kids for the most part although it to a
certain degree it is but we're talking
about people ages 25 to 80 years old and
I'm talking about the average point of
death for the app for the average male
who are buying beer products if they
decided that the ages of 21 to 24 are
more valuable than the entirety of their
market share then so be it let them take
a look at an 80 sales drop-off they
won't do it if the regional Distributors
say I will not carry a product if the
Affiliates say I'm not going to work
here anymore because we're not making
enough money and if the shareholders say
why did I lose 10 percent in two weeks
they will be forced to apologize knowing
the left will lose their minds and that
means the economic damage is scarier to
them than the left physical violence and
that is exactly the victory we need so
maybe maybe we lose the point is we must
persist in the easiest culture War
battle that's ever been laid before us
so that they are forced to apologize I
agree now that I agree with that 100 and
I will say this I will say this uh the
the trans Rights Movement
I do believe that it is actually a gift
from God for this country because I have
watched the right forever for my entire
life kind of dismissed the the newest
thing the newest culture War thing or
not take it that seriously or they'll
stop soon or surely there's an end to
this or it doesn't apply to me it's been
so easy to play that game the whole uh
I'm not gonna buy into any slippery
slope stuff I think this whole insane
movement has finally woken the right up
to that there is no end that this is not
the end this is this is not the end
either it gets worse I'm here it keeps
going down and down and down and down
and down that if we're going to get to
the place where we are telling children
and we're going to be telling young boys
just chop your penis off and you'll
become a woman I think that is finally
waking the right up to okay I'm not
dealing with bad I'm dealing with evil
and that is why the right has failed for
so long because bad May wake up in the
morning like that great CS Lewis
quote-un paraphrasing bad May wake up in
the morning and say you know I'm kind of
tired but demons do not demons don't
wake up and decide they've gone down the
drain enough because that's the
difference let me tell you because we we
did talk about this a bit the other day
as well yesterday was Ron Paul but
before that
I have gone on Twitter and I have
tweeted uh spay and neuter your children
to prevent overpopulation
not a peep from the left I have said I
actually am I don't mind abortion rights
and I think the left should have them
because they're ending their their
lineage and so the future will be
conservative not a peep nobody cared no
leftist said how dare you say something
so offensive
well the reality is they know it
and I think they're in many ways
that like they they know that abortion
and sterilizing their children will
result in less liberals and the future
being more conservative that's why they
have to go to the schools they don't
want to highlight the issue and say Tim
Poole said an awful thing because it
puts in the mind of all the Liberals
that hey wait a minute we are getting
rid of our kids now of course the
response from liberals is Tim liberals
have children too and I'm like oh yeah
but like 1.2 on average for every two
adults whereas conservatives have two
for two adults so conservatives
certainly aren't um at replacement
levels they're at or slightly below but
Liberals are substantially lower and
have been over the past 20 years you add
to the fact that you are pro-abortion
and more likely to have an abortion or
sterilize yourself or your kids it's
going to go even lower and given a long
enough time the math is simple you will
your your ideology and your family
lineage and your genealogy will cease to
exist now here's the point they not once
have smeared me over saying things like
that but you know what they smeared me
over relentlessly Budweiser you know why
over Target the fact that a major
corporation for no reason for no reason
the number one selling beer
the fact that they decided to embrace
wokeness has resulted in a four
percentage Point stock drop off five
billion dollars is scary because there's
other companies that aren't as big as
Anheuser-Busch who who maybe in azer
Bush will be okay as other companies
couldn't handle that these other
companies couldn't say we can't handle
all our regional Distributors cutting
off our brand if we if we adopt this ESG
stuff we're going to go to business look
at the backlash I'm not going anywhere
near that that is the social pressure we
are trying to create right now and the
point is this I will push on this as
hard as possible because for once we are
seeing quite possibly the easiest
culture War battle ever before us you
don't got to go outside in fact quite
the opposite you don't even have to not
drive here you don't even have to not
buy beer go buy all the beer you want
just buy a different one
yeah avoid Anheuser-Busch Brands buy a
local Brewery be careful with those too
by the way because Anheuser-Busch has
been buying those up one of my favorite
local ones in Houston
up by Anheuser-Busch make sure you look
that up first yeah someone published the
list of all the companies that they own
and all the breweries that they have and
it's it's multiple tweets of things I
tweeted it we are changed so people
could see it there's a large number
right
and then and then so it's they're the
company's called a b Dash inbev that's
the new company called and then eye
patch McCain what's his name uh Crenshaw
was also promoting another beer owned by
uh by uh anhydra Bush right uh and
Miller Coors has done a lot of Pride
stuff as well exactly however I don't
care as much about that I don't care
that you know this is the funny they're
like haha Marjorie Taylor green you're
saying by Miller Coors but here's their
LGBT Pride ad and and my response is oh
wow that's really cool they did an LGBT
Pride ad I have no problem with that my
problem is that Dylan Mulvaney is
targeting children you want to sell beer
to kids yeah I got a problem with that
you wanna you wanna tell kids to
sterilize themselves I got a problem
with that you want to promote those
ideas to kids I got a problem with that
and so if we can simply say hey look man
you know Dylan can post whatever Dylan
wants on Tick Tock Budweiser can sponsor
whoever they want and then we won't
touch their products that's the market
especially okay it was it's not no beer
commercials aren't no never mind never
mind let me let me jump to this story so
uh for all those that are concerned we
have this story from timcast.com
conservative dad's Ultra right beer
introduced combating Dylan Mulvaney's
sponsorship by Bud Light to the rest of
you welcome corporations stay the F away
from our kids now I want to say two
things one well I'll say three things
first I am not promoting or encouraging
anyone to buy this beer it's an
alcoholic product I'm not big on beer
but now you know it exists so do have
your own volition I will also say it is
good that conservatives are creating
Alternatives by whatever means necessary
to compete with these uh
with these woke corporations creating a
market opportunity to say hey you're
worried about what beer you might buy
here's a beer that you don't got to
worry about but more importantly it's
what Seth weathers who co-founded this
said stay the F away from our kids so
when Howard Stern said I don't
understand why Kid Rock is so mad it's
not nobody nobody screamed and cried at
least to this degree because Coors put a
pride flag ad out and said Miller Corps
supports LGBT Pride they sell tons of
beer in gay neighborhoods nobody cried
about that it's been going on for
general for two three generations or
whatever they're con they're angry that
people like Del Mulvaney Target children
and the corporations are targeting
children and I'll just say it's twofold
why is a beer company sponsoring an
individual's primary audience is
teenagers
that's just like didn't we have this
huge thing about Joe Camel and cartoons
marketing cigarettes to kids
are awesome the VP did say she wants a
younger audience she wants young people
to drink or the brand would quote die
and that to me in itself that to me well
whether it's a lie or not it's still
coming from a mentality of I want young
kids to drink beer which is absolutely
horrible for them horrible for their
cognitive function there's some studies
even showing how people in their 20s
have their brains still developing so to
have that skewed and manipulated and
heard in so many different ways by
alcohol that's something else that
should be called out here and instead of
saying hey let's drink another beer hey
don't drink that poison at all it's full
of uh endocrine disruptors it's filled
with fluoride it's filled with horrible
substances that are really bad for you
and I think this is an opportunity to
say hey I'm not going to poison myself
and let's not poison each other either
let's make an alternative better choice
for ourselves well look I I agree I
don't drink beer I think beer is bad but
I think the overall majority of human
beings on the planet love beer and beer
is actually responsible for him human
civilization as it is do you guys know
this yeah with the with the water the
bacteria in there I mean that's true too
but the issue was that humans were
nomadic until we discovered the beer
making process or a rudimentary form of
it and then we had to stop moving around
so that the beer could ferment we liked
beer so much we were like let's just
stick around here and grow more of this
stuff to make more of that stuff and so
that's I don't know if it's true it's
urban legend or whatever they say that
beer was the beginning of Agriculture
for us because we were like yo this
stuff makes me feel good and so we want
to make more of it so I think beer is
great I think there are a lot of people
that understand drinking heavily is bad
for you but crack and open a cold one
with the boys after a long hard day of
work you show up to the to the bar or
whatever and you grab an ice cold an ice
cold Ultra Rite
and then you're just relaxing with
everybody and you're and you're you know
you know ripping each other and you're
having a good time I can certainly
understand why people enjoy that moment
and I think it's fairly obvious as to
why this story became so big it's
because
let me slow down and put it this way
like eight like five years ago I said
sooner or later the woke stuff will come
to Major League Sports and
people will start to understand what it
really is the rules of the NBA are
arbitrary we made them up it's a social
construct we decided where the where the
free throw line is we decided how many
players are on a team and we could
decide that half the team should be
women
and that will happen now it's happening
in the other direction it's happening to
women's teams first but I I said this
was going to happen
I thought that when it got to the point
where someone like Colin Kaepernick
would kneel or the NFL would be forced
to have half of their football team be
women that's when you'd see a major
Revolt because regular people love
sports and all that but while sports did
play a big role with people being upset
it didn't go that far I should have made
the obvious prediction beer you screw it
dude's beer and they're gonna lose it
and now you got a bunch of regular guys
being like why is my beer gay you know
and now they're asking that question and
it's spreading and the morality of it
still has to be considered here because
if you're Dylan Mulvaney right and you
look at your Tick Tock you're like oh
what's my analytics who am I reaching
who am I talking to who's my core
audience I'll bet you're uh you know
I'll bet a lot of money right now that's
probably a lot of underage children and
then to say hey hey kids look at me
drink some beer have fun that's
ridiculous that's absolutely disgusting
that's something that should have been
called out here by the mainline Society
saying hey
um even even but you know Anheuser-Busch
should have said who's the core audience
here why are we trying to advertise to
small children for an alcoholic beverage
that will stunt their cognitive function
and growth that right there should be
the conversation in the discussion and
is repundant and disgusting in its in
its in its face this is what I was going
to bring up earlier I believe that it's
illegal for beer commercials on TV to
show people drinking the beer in the
commercial they're allowed to hold it
and show it and have it but if they
actually drink get the it's become Elite
as far as I know that's illegal but in
this somehow because it's on the
internet they're allowed to that it
should be it should be a violation
that's illegal you can't you can't deal
with any was sipping that thing in the
bathtub in that commercial
I looked it up I looked it up apparently
uh the average age of a tick tock user
is just under 21 years old so you have
an individual who is whose primary
audience and I believe Don mulvadin's
audience is probably younger than that
the reason why the average age of a tick
tock user is just under 21 is because
you have to factor in the amount of
people who are older than that and how
it averages out in the age that means
it's probably I would say the median age
the plurality of users are probably
around 16 17 maybe 18 years old you then
have a smaller uh portion which are
probably in their late 30s 40s or
whatever
and then it averages out and it pulls up
the average age a little bit making it
sound like the average person who get is
older when in actuality the majority of
users are probably well under 21. I
don't think you've I think Don
Mulvaney's audience is probably 14 15.
and that's and Tick Tock is targeting
these these kids intentionally and
you're a role model you're a role model
for a lot of younger individuals and the
same let's be honest here it goes for
Joe Rogan if you take a can of beer and
you open it you're inspiring other
people to do that as well and and some
people may say oh you're making too much
of a big deal of it but little things
like that little Impressions like that
absolutely matter especially with what
you endorse what you drink and how many
people look up to you as a role model as
you're going to have a lot of people
copying you and and those are decisions
that I think people should be thinking
about seriously if they're you know
influencers but why can't we why can't
we accept and I know you probably do but
why can't we accept that that's why they
do it they know they're Role Models they
know well I I I believe the right is
finally getting better at waking up as
we realize what horrible anti-human scum
these people are they're after your kids
on purpose they're they're on Nick Jr
for a reason they're on Tick Tock to 15
year olds for a reason they're on Disney
for a reason they didn't trip and oh
whoops I'm at Disney
they're after your kids on purpose oh
let me elaborate elaborate real quick
real quick
um when we're talking about mastectomies
for children
when they when they're giving young
girls mastectomies we actually looked at
the stats and it's in the thousands I
believe it's like in the over the past
few years it's like a couple thousand
and the left will say something like why
do you care so much it doesn't happen
then why was it I think it was Blue's
Clues which is a children's show
depicted a character with mastectomy
scars
why would they want kids to see that
well I believe it was uh let me make
sure I can I can look this up and get it
right I think it was on Blues Clues
there was a pride event showing
characters with mastectomy scars
so all Divi correction while you're
doing that uh it's not illegal to show
people drinking beer on TV it's highly
uh frowned upon by the agency television
agencies since it's like a
post-prohibition thing I was told a long
time ago that it was illegal and that's
why we don't see it but apparently it's
just a voluntary thing that they don't
so look at this here you go Snopes did
Blues Clues Pride Parade feature a
beaver with top scars true that's from
Snopes now why are they showing your
children Pride parades with people with
top scars the issue is I may not be
like when they come out and they say
something like oh not that many kids are
getting it you're exaggerating it's like
I never came out and said every kid was
getting it this is the weird thing when
Joe when Matt Walsh was on Joe Rogan and
Rogan asked Matt Walsh how many kids are
doing this Matt Wallace what did he say
millions or something like that
uh he said some ridiculous number and
then everyone called him out because
it's thousands it's a it's in terms of
cross-sex hormones I think it's around
50 000 in terms of puberty blockers it's
like 17 000 and in terms of uh
mastectomies for for uh adolescent girls
it's in the thousands like between one
and two thousand and I was like well I
don't I can't speak for anybody else but
I never came out and said oh heavens me
so many there's too many kids getting
this it must be in the millions I was
like one kid getting this is not good
and you know why because in Scandinavia
they piloted this and then said whoa
this isn't working and abandoned it and
in the UK they piloted this and then
said whoa this is not working and
abandon it and not only were the
children that they were trying to treat
still suicidal or or depressed the
surgeries and the and the medical
intervention actually increased or or
made these things worse or did nothing
at all so all it does is increase risk
my point is why are we encouraging
children to do it it's if if you're
gonna come out and be like ah it's only
50 000 on these hormones then I'll be
like okay if you don't think that's too
many what would be too many if the left
says who cares not that many kids are
getting it my response is what is the
number by then by by which you would
then say I am allowed to be concerned
that children are undergoing treat
treatments that we've already seen in
for other countries fail what what's the
number is it not 50 is it 75 is it 100
is it 200 okay here's the point if
Blue's Clues keeps pushing this stuff
give it five ten years we will be at a
hundred thousand how about we just call
it out right now and say let's not get
to that number well let's be honest
we're not going near far enough to stop
it right now either I'm glad we're
finally waking up and finally calling it
out and we're what do you mean we're
passing laws we're we're we're Banning
it across the country passing laws we
have the major the biggest children's
organization in the United States of
America Disney
sexually grooming children with this
stuff over and over and over again and I
realize I don't and I applaud Florida
for what they're doing going after tax
exempt status We're a nation with many
children in it if you have a corporation
in your nation that has dedicated part
of its mission to attacking the children
of your nation that Corporation should
immediately be shut down immediately
should sit in the National Guard should
send in the race but well if we're
interested in real solutions yeah okay
so so we're Banning it in what a few
states where we're at 20 States now okay
so that well by my map in a couple years
that leaves us 30 States who are still
doing it and will slowly incrementally
do this and what's going to happen is
we're eventually going to have a bunch
of kind of red states where you can't do
most of this stuff but you can do a
little and then these blue Sodom and
Gomorrah freaking hell holes where we're
carving where Dr Frankenstein is just
operating on these kids every other day
and where did that where do we end up we
ended up so evil we ended up still bad
that's exactly right we're not nipping
it in the butt in the right way but
we're finally engaging but we're still
taking half measures all we do is half
pressure after half measure I disagree
because I don't think there's much
Beyond making it illegal
if if we're headed towards a point where
and I've talked about this we had the
story of uh Jeff younger I believe his
name was he was on this show yeah yeah
Jeff he has a kid who his wife took to
California which is a sanctuary I
remember and I'm like look man the
number one thing we don't want we don't
want Civil War we don't want divorce we
don't want violence because then China
wins because then our foreign
adversaries just take over and the U.S
just it'll be it'll be conflict nobody
wants to experience but if they are
unwilling if if I'll put it this way
the right tends to be
as a collective whatever you would call
the right in the culture War I would say
actually relatively of limited morals
meaning the Christian conservatives are
particularly moralistic and have a set
of morals but then you have a lot of
Libertarians you have a lot of
traditional liberals and the morals
within this group are disparate they
differ the one thing they hold is like
truth what is true what is not true so
you can have an individual like Jimmy
Dore who disagrees on economic policy
for opinion reasons based on what we
don't know to be absolute but he'll tell
you oh yeah these things did happen I
agree with you you're right that news
story did happen I read that that's true
and so the issue I see is with
everything the left is doing pertaining
to the expansion of abortion to the
point of birth and the um what do they
call gender affirming sanctuaries the
only end result of all of this in my
opinion is going to be conflict because
of what we I'll take a look at history
we take a look at the history of the
Civil War and the moral issues
surrounding slavery
and what was it there were a lot of
people in northern states
and despite the fact that Northerners
were extremely racist and they overall
did not care about slavery there were
large factions of abolitionists who only
cared about slavery and were willing to
travel to other states and territories
to outright murder people to end slavery
and there's interesting questions about
do we believe those people were morally
Justified so let's stop and put it this
way
do people
hold John Brown in high esteem
dancers yes they do despite the fact
that he was a murderous terrorist
that's by the fact that he and his sons
would walk up to slave owners and just
murder them and for me I'm kind of like
I think that's a bad thing and we don't
want anything like that happening now
because you have to understand what that
means it means either antifa will
determine that our systems our
institutions are worthy of being burnt
to the ground which they they do and the
violence will escalate or then you get
conservatives who act like John Brown
which only makes the conflict worse and
then you end up in Mass War the question
of who wins I'm not entirely sure
I will just say I don't know with
watching all of this at what point
people come back together and this
country heals and I'm not convinced it's
possible because you look at what
happened in 2020 with the uh the war the
the election war game where apparently
John podesta
we're all playing this game said that if
Donald Trump were to have won in 2020
the West Coast uh States should secede
from the union like where does all of
this lead to the secession uh and the
breakup of the United States talk James
Lindsay was talking to Vivek ramaswamy
on vivek's YouTube channel a few days
ago and they were saying it's like in
war in in combat if you want to destroy
your enemy you do not surround them
because if you surround them they'll
fight to the death if you want to
destroy your enemy you surround them on
three sides and you give them one Escape
Route and then when they flee when they
see that route then they take it and
they flee that's when you jump on them
and Destroy them when they're routing so
a lot in Ukraine right now too by the
way it's the same in the culture War
what's happening is they're giving
people an Escape Route in the guise of
national divorce and that's the mistake
do not take that path that's that's the
destruction of everything is if we if we
think that the solution States yeah if
we if we assume the path is this is the
dissolution maybe no hold on hold on
that's one Escape Route that we've been
given what United States these United
States no no no no no no no what what
United States the one we want to exist
the one that actually exists like we've
been talking about things like Tim keeps
bringing up about European nations far
ahead of us who have stopped these
horrible procedures for children but
look let's keep going back let's keep
going back to covet these European
nations that I personally and I know
many of us have mocked oh look at
socialist idiot Europeans were far ahead
of us here we here in the United States
of America especially on the right we
have a very nostalgic view of the
country that we still think exists now
there are still gigantic pockets of this
country that do exist in that way but
the government in its current form and I
will include our education system
Entertainment System our Sport Systems
this country is one of the most broken
and corrupt countries in the entire
planet and there's not it's not even a
question about it one of the most broken
and corrupt countries in the entire
planet what United States are we talking
about because it's not the United States
of Grandpa and worldwide or two are on
the beaches of Normandy and it's not the
United States of America from the year
2000. it's the United States of America
where our pride Flags fly from embassies
across we sexually mutilate children in
this nation over and over again we have
politician after politician after
politician in this country that took
part in all that covid Madness dumping
all over everybody keeping their seats
of power after they did so they all got
richer while we have inflation raging
and Mom and Pops can't buy eggs at the
grocery store the United States GOP and
Senate or GOP and Democrats in the
Senate came together and passed a 1.7
trillion dollar bill that was just a big
handout to all of their friends it
didn't even it didn't even pretend like
it did anything for the people then we
can do this we have a broke we don't
have a United States of America that's a
lie we all have a United States that's a
nostalgic lie and that's it no that's
not it but but Let's do let's do
acknowledge reality huge
pockets of the country that can be saved
but let's let's let let's stop talking
about we the people they know we the
people everyone's seen that pool I'm
sure you guys have talked about it on
the show what was it 68 of Democrats
thought you should be arrested or locked
in your home if you didn't take a covet
vaccine don't tell me I'm sharing a
country with that person that person's
my enemy that's it
of course
we're a late stage Republic is what we
are we're late stage Republicans and the
next stage is is what Empire uh no I I
hope not I I believe that it's empire
because history probably says that it's
empire and that's just someone across
the Rubicon yeah that's freaking
horrible but yeah I I believe the era
and this really sucks because I love
teeny tiny government I believe the era
of limited government is laughably past
us that we will never get back to that
again because the people only people who
crew crave limited government are people
who've experienced real tyranny like the
founders have but since we haven't
really really experienced the teeth of
that yet now it's just big government
right and big government yet left so
it's either Empire or whether it's some
official divorce or secession or
whatever kind of crazy word you want to
put on it we are living in two Americas
and you better get to the part where
they don't want to cut your son's penis
off and you better get there now because
the other part ain't backing off they're
not apologizing they're not moderating
they're not backing away in fact they're
taking our people and they're throwing
them in prison which is why don't buy in
Hazard Bush
no more he said there was a coup in the
United States in 1963 when the
government killed Kennedy and uh that
was it just shook me I I think he's
right and I don't know
what to do about it I the Federal Bureau
of Investigation just got busted
infiltrating the Catholic church I I
brought this I brought up this point
recently and I want people to really
take in what this means when the
government when the United States
government when they focus on one when
they Mission focus on one enemy they
destroy that enemy they've done it in
the past with the Soviet Union Cold War
Focus everything CIA FBI government
policy your Economic Policy your
military everything focused destroy this
Soviet Union took them down but then we
focused on Islamic Jihad don't get
started Luke we got focused on Islamic
Jihad the CIA how many of those people
how many of those people did we kill
across the planet and I'm not not
bad-mouthing killing terrorists how many
did we kill across the planet millions
and people need to understand now that
same Mission Focus across NSA CIA FBI
United States government state
department they are mission focused on
the American right within our borders we
will have people say things like they're
destroying our military no they're
purging the dissident right out of the
military
and the police because they're building
one and they're building one for a
different purpose I don't believe in
this idea that we're just one election
away from home there's no we're not I
certainly don't think so either and I've
been talking about this it's been a
couple years actually there was a video
where a guy is attacked by antifa and is
fleeing and the police show up apologize
to antifa and arrest him yep yep and I
saw the same thing in Dallas Texas red
state of Dallas Texas some child drag
show and of course antifa shows up to
beat up anyone who protests it and the
Dallas Police Department not not the
antifa guys in Mass with weapons they
mob the one dude who was trying to walk
down the sidewalk by himself and he's
yelling at him he said why are you
harassing me there's some angry violent
right there I saw this in uh in Canada
it was um trucker protest press for
Truth uh
Dan Dix Dan Dix recorded the videotape
he was uh filming and he got surrounded
by far left extremists so the police
grabbed him and and said if you don't
leave we'll arrest you and he said what
they attacked me we don't care get out
or we'll arrest you and so this is the
thing I got to tell you part of it feels
really good I I imagine Luke is probably
you know every so often smiling a little
bit that conservatives who supported all
of the the expansion of police powers
and of the of DHS and things like that
in the Patriot Act are now the ones who
are being targeted by it because it's
probably a bit of shot and foot the only
problem is we're all caught in the same
same Maelstrom yep definitely not
smiling since uh again this is affecting
everyone and people have to understand
this is also going to affect the left as
well the revolution eats its own and
first when we exactly and when we look
at historically what happens during
these big political shifts uh especially
in China especially during the cultural
revolution especially in in the Soviet
Union you see a lot of the Top members
you see a lot of the people who helped
this new party get into Power be purged
right away sacrificed or murdered and
genocided in so many different ways and
this is why this is such a dangerous
turn turning point in America and after
9 11 I was warning people hey you know
the Patriot Act destroying the
Constitution spying on American citizens
torturing renditioning people drone
bombing and killing people that are
American citizens maybe is not a good
idea and I think this is why the right
doesn't have as much leverage doesn't
have have as much respect and why we
have such a big cultural pushback
because during the bush years they have
essentially destroyed this country
destroyed the US Constitution indebted
this country printed money out of thin
air and has led us to this horrible
situation where now the people on the
left are like well if they get in power
they're going to create more war they're
going to destroy our constitution so we
got to do it first and now the Democrats
are doing it and now the Republicans are
aware the Democrats used to be and the
seats are changing but in reality we're
just being propelled left and right
towards this totalitarian status hell
hole and more people are saying we just
got to vote for the lesser of two evils
and this is what led us here and we've
been warning about it we've been warning
about it for such a long time well and
everyone said you're crazy you're kooky
you're a conspiracy nope here we are
today and there's and and I don't know
how we're going to go back shout out to
Dr Ron Paul we had him on last night it
was an honor and a privilege and Luke
shared with me a meme from the show so
Luke's sitting over here and he says he
asks of Dr Paul are they malicious or
are they ignorant are they stupid or are
they evil and what did Dr Paul say Ron
Paul Just Smiles like yes
I was like which one he was like no yes
yeah we got great great response and
then he talked about how they are
ignorant and they are that's absolutely
evil in many instances and and this is
what happens when you have this two kind
of duopoly system that has hijacked our
government and again when it comes to
you know even even the administration
before this the national debt the the
lockdowns the the emergencies that
doesn't help anyone as well printing
money out of thinner giving everyone two
thousand dollar checks which amounted to
nothing by the way compared to all the
corporate banking bailouts which as you
said were huge sums of money that they
just gave their friends Republicans and
Democrats Republicans and Democrats
Republicans were all for lockdowns
Republicans were all for passing these
trillion dollar bills just like the
Democrats they were attacking Sweden
they were attacking Sweden and their own
fellow Republican politicians that were
like you know maybe 15 days to slow the
spread is a really bad idea when we
allow Walmart to be open but we shut
down the small mama pop stores maybe
that's a bad idea and then the president
of the United States at the time
attacked that politician very vicious
and you know let's let's call it out
here let's be let's be honest with
ourselves uh because I think this is a
major issue of concern and and major
issues that are holding the right back
from actually achieving something good
and again this is why I don't have a lot
of faith in the right I have a lot of
faith in the American people I don't
vote that don't support the system that
are sick and tired of this bullcrap and
are are taking matters into their own
health by being personally responsible I
I think we're on a track to Victory to
be completely honest I I think we win at
the end of all of this I think the the
future will be 50 to 100 years the
country will be much more patriotic it
will be much more like that as you put
it World War II greatest Generation you
know go America I'll give you a few
reasons why if we follow the straws
house uh how generational Theory we are
in the fourth turning which means just
by the nature of how Generations operate
we are in the worst of it and the worst
of it will create strong men who create
Good Times who will in turn then later
on create weak men but that means the
next the next phase is the first we're
in the fourth turning a period of tumult
will happen and then there will be a
period where we start picking up and
climbing up
so I think we're seeing the worst of it
now over the next couple of years it's
predicted to get very bad maybe it's
World War III maybe it's Civil War maybe
it's hot War maybe it's not and then
we'll have a period where the strong men
start to rebuild as we have seen
throughout history in this country and
many others the other issue that I think
is worth pointing out is
that conservatives have kids they may
not have enough kids but all that
matters is they have twice as many as
liberals Liberals are more likely to
abort their kids more likely to
sterilize themselves and their kids and
conservatives right now have actually
been pushing the talking point of having
as many kids as possible which means we
may actually see a boost due to the
culture among what I would just refer to
as the freedom faction because it's not
just conservatives it's also disaffected
liberals and Libertarians people are
saying have more kids have at least two
have three because Liberals are having
one on average and and if that give that
20 years you know what that means if
every conservative family has four
children right now in 20 years you will
have four times the youth voter base now
of course the left tries to indoct
indoctrinate your kids but what what
else are we seeing in the cultural
Zeitgeist among the right is homeschool
your kids bring your kids into into
homeschooling pods and get away from
these schools the other big factor that
I think shows run a path to Victory is
the fleeing of these Urban centers to
places like Florida and Texas people who
actually pay attention are moving away
from these nightmarish hellholes and the
best part
I suppose the worst part for people to
live in the cities we just saw in
Portland kawava a coffee shop announced
finally they were shutting their doors
down because the violence and extremism
had grown too much for them to handle
and they couldn't take care of their
employees industry is collapsing and
they will soon have no access to
resources the one benefit the United
States had over say the Soviet Union is
that when the revolution happened they
topped down just started killing people
and implemented their weirdo communist
garbage who destroyed everything but we
have the Second Amendment and we're a
very very large country with smaller
subcultures within this country which
means when California La and SF for
instance get woke they go broke it will
be extremely difficult for the the law
enforcement of California to go to Texas
to force their way of life what does
that mean as you mentioned earlier Jesse
There are pockets of this country that
are still going strong and can be saved
it doesn't matter those those Pockets
aren't going to go anywhere you're not
going to be able to go in there and take
them down in fact tax is turning more
red Florida became a reliable red state
which means when California collapses
under the weight of its Democrat policy
garbage we're now seeing I I covered the
story it's gonna I did a segment on this
earlier but I'm putting it up on Friday
homeless camps popping up in Beverly
Hills you know what that means it means
all of these Hollywood celebrities who
invested their money in property are not
going to have a penny to give Grandma
because they're going to be underwater
hey look I got a 5 million movie
contract so I bought a 10 million dollar
house now I got I got an 8 million
dollar loan on that house but it's only
worth five million dollars I can't sell
it what can I do with it nobody wants to
come here there's homeless people in
crime everywhere guess what in places
like Texas and Florida things are
getting better in West Virginia things
are getting better but in the big cities
things are getting worse as long as all
of this continues the insulated and
somewhat isolated conservative Pockets
that are thriving will Thrive the
institutions of the left will eat
themselves and Destroy themselves the
beer companies will collapse for trying
to sell beer to children that don't want
to drink it or I should say to young
college kids destroying their Market
there's a reason why we say get what go
broke it's a tendency not a law over a
long enough period of time we have seen
more than enough examples of companies
embracing wellness and then losing money
because of it now of course they have
institutional capture they've got
weapons in the federal government but I
don't think in the long run that matters
because the weight is pressing on them
not us we are the people who are living
outside of the Cities who are leaving
these cities and getting away from it
and then thriving places like Florida
where Rhonda said this story locked down
but he reopened up and then people
flooded to Florida where there's
beautiful beaches there's great weather
and people having a party then there's
Texas Texas is turning redder as well
because people are coming here because
they want freedom which means all of the
attempts of the left to take over has
created an inverse pressure system which
is sending people out of their states
which costs them power which reduces
their revenue reduces their income
reduces their influence
and then they abort and sterilize their
kids so certainly we want to stop all
these bad things but I think the long
run is if we set back and just said stay
the course and keep doing everything
you're doing I think in a hundred years
it's over we completely won but if we
persist in the culture war and make sure
we're homeschooling our kids make sure
we aren't buying Anheuser-Busch products
20 to 30 years 20 to 30 years of
conservatives having four kids each and
you've got a voting block that has been
raised on winning a culture war and
that's all that matters four times the
new voters entering the system and it's
not even 20 it's 18 years in 18 years
from this day
conservatives can have four more votes
per family that's one for you one for
your significant other and four kids
granted you're not gonna have four kids
all at once so maybe within the span of
23 years you might have four kids who
are a voting age but liberals aren't
going to have any of that I would say
maybe and that's a very optimistic uh
look and perspective to have there which
which again is important to kind of
explore here but when we have open
immigration when we have populations
being replaced in California in New York
with another voting base that
particularly votes left uh with them
also making very significant moves
against the Second Amendment with them
crashing the petrol dollar with a a
native population crash of the western
world I think we're dealing with
something very severe that could also
happen in the exact inverse as you
described here as we're dealing with an
anti-human agenda that encourages the
destruction of the fan of the family
unit stops reproduction and pushes a
larger depopulation agenda that of
course is a total totalitarian control
grid so on on those aspects it could
swing either way but that open
immigration problem is something also
that I think we should be looking at I I
think I I think the southern border is a
crisis I think it is an issue and I
think there's a reason why Democrats
don't want to shut that to to shut the
border down to actually control it given
given 10 years California brings in more
and more people
and a lot of people on the right say
it's because they're they're voting
illegally they're not it doesn't they
don't need to vote the population of
illegal immigrants gives them more
electoral votes period and electoral
votes are the real votes that matter
California knows this New York knows
this Joe Biden knows this that's why
they bring in people bring them to these
states it changes the Electoral makeup
not
by having them vote by increasing the
amount of districts in the state so I
think in the in 2010 California had one
extra Congressional vote based on
non-citizens
so they're this they're not voting but
they're getting a vote I don't think
what do you think matters anymore are
you optimistic or pessimistic from the
two perspectives inside you you heard
here oh he's way too optimistic there's
no way well here's why I I would agree
with you our our big challenge right now
is waking up the Normie right and this
is going to be the challenge of what I'm
about to say because it's not going to
apply to anybody who watches stimcast
any night I'm talking about my neighbors
all my neighbors 92 93 Republican
neighborhood we get together every
weekend it's it's we're all having a
blast we drink beer Luke we play no play
horseshoes we have crawfish boils the
kids play in the art it's it's it's a
blast they agree with me on all my
values they agree with everyone in this
room in general obviously we're all
different in our basic values but
they're putting their kids in college
oh man I'm so proud little Aiden got
into Stanford I'm so excited where'd
Jaden go oh Jaden got into Harvard
that's exciting the the people who share
our values are so out of touch with how
evil the traditional institutions are in
this nation the the institutions that
they previously have attended and that
they will not only still patronizing
since these institutions they'll write
them big checks they'll send their kids
there and then they'll come to
Neighborhood parties and brag about it
and I'll just sit there with my jaw
hanging open because I know the love and
care that parent took with that kid I
know that kid 18 years of love and care
and values and manners and you're so
proud but you're so unplugged you're so
not wired in that you send them off to
the wolves and like clockwork two years
later Jesse I can't believe it Aiden
came home he's got 20 rings in his face
and a Joe Biden sticker on his car and
he hates my guts and what do you want me
to tell you the Normie right the leave
me alone right but I just want to go to
work I just want to play for I just want
to watch football it's not just an army
right do you know how many people we've
had on this show who talk about the
exact same thing I've we've had
conservative guests come on the show who
complain about the left say yeah my kid
just got into college so I'm really
excited for that and I'm like do you
listen to your own videos
but I know I go through the same thing I
go to the same thing with people I know
with people I love the the right has
such a difficult time
accepting where we are and I understand
that because that's human nature I don't
even just want to indict the right it is
human nature to deny the reality of your
situation for as long as you possibly
can because it's that bad or you don't
want to bother with it that's this is
why I laugh and mock people on the right
when they say things like well we're the
silent majority what does that matter
majority means nothing they grab the
seats of power they they find the choke
holds of power that's why the Wright
will sit there and scream all day long
when there's some child drag show in
their blood red town in in Oklahoma
somewhere you know why because you were
busy being the silent majority and the
Communists were busy taking over your
Public Library taking over your city
government while you were flipping
burgers and playing fantasy football he
was grabbing the seats of power and when
you explain these things to them they're
shocked I remember just like it was
yesterday one night just one last point
on this one night I'm sitting around the
table is 10 couples there and we're all
and I don't talk a lot of politics they
all know what I do but I don't like to
do that that at a party so I just kind
of chill and relax but it came up
someone asked me it's about something
and I brought up ESG
now we're talking with successful people
here all of them wired in our values
successful people here not one man or
woman at that table had ever even heard
ESG and when I explained what ESG was
and told them all I said everyone right
now pick up your cell phone and look up
your bank I guarantee your bank has a
dedicated ESG page on it they all
thought I was a nut job conspiracy
theorist you could have heard a pin drop
in there over the next five minutes as
they discovered the reality of the world
they live in until the Normie right that
shares normal values realizes it's in a
war a culture war and there will be one
Victor then 20 years maybe a hundred
they got a lot of waking up to do and
it's going to take years they're
rebranding ESG by the way according to
James Lindsay it's you're going to stop
hearing it they'll be like oh yes she
was crazy now it's called like Global
something I'll bring that up tomorrow to
clarify you know you talked about people
denying reality until the very last
second when it's painful I think that
with voting I don't think voting matters
anymore
yeah well here's it may or may not now
this is what I want to explain obviously
they cheat in elections and when I say
that don't tell me they don't there's a
reason the entire Democratic party
thinks voter ID is illegal that's it
should be illegal that's insane you
should obviously have to show an ID the
only reason you wouldn't want that is
because you cheat and want to cheat some
more so don't tell me they don't cheat
but setting that aside the right again
back to the Normie right even people who
are activists activists of some way you
know what our participation is in
primaries 20 Democrats participate 50 in
primary Wisconsin yeah exactly
Republicans 20 so we wonder why the
Democratic party's gone full-blown
Communists in the past 10 years and yet
we still have a bunch of Limp wrist and
losers running the Low T GOP in this
country that's because the Communists
show up and vote and and what we what do
we do we throw a trump sticker on our
car and say Donald Trump will save us
and we skip the local primary or even
worse we show up and vote for the same
turd who just voted but listen listen I
agree with you on all that but I don't
think that changes anything I just said
well you said that I don't agree with
because having kids is not enough it's
important but it's not grabbing the
seats of power if you're gonna grab kids
and still send Aiden off to Stanford
then you didn't it's not a Net game that
that I understand but that still doesn't
matter the cities are destroying
themselves this stuff doesn't work if
someone if someone came to me and said I
am deeply concerned by this new movement
of people who are you know harming
themselves I'd be like well over a long
enough period of time they won't exist
because they've harmed themselves you
could say that about the CCP having the
one child policy but they didn't destroy
themselves because they have such an
authoritarian weaponized system
but that's that's not what I'm talking
about see the thing about the CCP is
that they just kidnap and murder people
and while the United States certainly
has those capabilities as well they're
not the U.S has safeguards and
protections that I think will be
weakened be damaged are being eroded but
will probably stand through a stand
strong enough to where
I I think over the long enough period of
time a combination of factors the
foundation of this country and and the
Constitution itself with all the attacks
against it and the fact that it's big
and partially decentralized more so than
many of these other countries
as long as we keep up the culture War
battle as long as we say don't buy
Anheuser-Busch here's all you got to do
Jesse when you have those parties just
let your neighbors the couples that are
coming over say hey don't don't buy any
beer my treat I'm taking care of it then
you go and you buy the beer and you
don't buy Bush on that one I will say
this for some good news this was this
past weekend was probably the first
weekend I hung out with those same
neighbors where to a man every time Dick
and Harry showed up and they were all
talking about the Bud Light thing and it
was all negative this was the thing that
really snapped the end of what I'm
saying economic managers nuts yeah this
was the thing they they all brought it
to me gotta get rid of the Bud Light
good grief this is horrible won't be
buying that again that's what I'm saying
when I saw the reaction to the Bud Light
story I said I think we have an
opportunity to reach regular people with
this striking at beer was the biggest
mistake they made but they had to make
it I'm imagining there's this great
Battlefield and we'll make a metaphor of
it with the with the awoke people
looking over a map and and it's the year
is 20 11 and they're like okay our first
move is to send our troops into video
games and video game journalism because
older people won't won't see and that
means the commanders on the right will
ignore it it may bother young people but
if we get a foothold there we can then
spread our troops around and gain
control of movies and literature and and
TV shows and then the committal tenant
says but sir what about this area and he
points to beer no no don't go near that
one we don't have near enough power in
the culture War to strike at something
as prominent as beer and they thought
now was that time and maybe I don't
think so but maybe they said we have
gained enough ground in enough
institutions to where we can now muster
us an incursion on beer
and they're hoping that the right is
weakened and you more or less to the
point where their weird insane cult
garbage will actually successfully take
over beer I'm confident that they don't
have the power to do so especially if
forces like ours tell people to resist
to this degree problem I'm having you
guys and I'm severely black pilled on
voting maybe you can help me that they
are tallying votes on proprietary voting
machines in in Pub in private makes me
feel so
right I I just don't want to deviate
from the cultural stuff I know the
cultural surface of the victory that is
the win but we're talking about it's
holistically like
your metaphor about raising young
conservative kids that then they will
vote and fix the system I don't feel
that the voting I didn't say anything
yes but what I'm saying is right now our
victory has to be cultural the point is
have kids
overwhelm the system to a degree where
whatever you think it doesn't matter
if if we're looking at four to one in
the votes you win hands down if no
matter what's done in secret how it
doesn't matter it just doesn't matter
that's what Stalin said it doesn't
matter who who make who votes it matters
uh I think I think my cameras are not
plugged in we better plug it yeah I
think it's about to die you need to plug
it in I'll take it oh I see the power
we're gonna say Jesse Yeah well it's a
good thing I noticed that it's about to
cut out if I can maybe ease your
concerns maybe not
obviously everyone knows there's a bunch
of crap going on when it comes to voting
but that doesn't that doesn't change
your community that unless you live in
Philadelphia or in New York or something
like that your community those are the
votes that matter who's who's on your
school board who's who's your D.A who's
your sheriff who's on your city council
there's not some gigantic uh election
cheating scheme in your community we
have we here I live in Texas May 6th we
have elections are are the Republicans
going to actually show up and
participate now they're not sexy it's
not president it's not Trump but
DeSantis in the presidency they're
boring freaking city council candidates
and all that we get out voted in those
and it's not cheating they show up two
three four to one while we sit at home
and are we gonna show up or not okay
they have an urban Advantage because of
population density it's easier for them
to expand their ground game and harder
for people in rural areas maybe either
of you come over I've become overly
obsessed with Federal politics and I've
become do you realize all all the right
has even if you consider yourself there
all the right has because the right has
this horrible savior complex because
we're busy we have jobs families they
they want one person to just win just
when the presidency and fix it fix it
Trump uh just fix it to santis not
either one of those guys is going to be
able to fix anything it starts locally
it starts in your community we start
local protect your community fortify it
and then we expand it from there
eventually we get to Washington DC
Freedom's never going to come from
Washington DC let me ask you about uh
that Gathering you had whether your
neighbors came to you like like let's
get specific on that like so so what
happened they show up and they're like
hey Jesse what's up with this beer thing
uh well we were who knows all the
conversation that was going on that all
the the beer thing this weekend it was
it was immediate to him it was not it
was not well something that came up
after a while everybody because everyone
usually drives golf carts around the
neighborhood or just walks to wherever
we're going seeing who's out and about
lawn chairs and stuff like that everyone
as they walked up was talking about they
was the number one subject on everyone's
mine they were all talking about it I'm
getting rid of it I'm done forever crap
I'm embarrassed I didn't bring mine
because I didn't want to get made fun of
I'm never buying it that's it right
there it was it I didn't want to get
made fun of oh yeah that's the power of
see this is what the left uses they use
shame but if the dude Bros are concerned
about being made fun of
they're not going to do it but that's
why I was saying like you can simplify
it for everybody and be like don't worry
guys Beer's on me and they go yeah and
then you show up with a different brand
do you guys think that that we need to
unify against a common enemy do you
think that we need that that's why I
wrote the anti-communist manifesto which
can be purchased at jessiekellybook.com
no no listen and all seriously in all
seriousness that's why that's why I talk
about anti-communism so much I the Right
must unify if we talk about Libertarians
and conservatives in a nationalists and
all these different parts of the right
and I'm not dismissing any of those
parts and the different points any of
them make I have I have my own desires
there but what we're doing when we talk
when we spend all this time what should
the end result be should should tax tax
rates be here or there sure what we're
actually doing is we're sitting inside
the courtyard of a castle and we're
we're we're coming at each other about
what color the drapes should be and how
tall the building should be while the
enemy hordes are coming through the
front gates to kill us all we stop the
left first or all these arguments the
right has about what should or shouldn't
be they're all meaningless none of it
means anything at all these people will
steal kill and destroy everything once
we stop them then we can have that
argument and anti-governmentism is all
that matters here's the important thing
I think needs to be said
these people have been engaged in this
for a lot longer than you oh yeah Pros
you look at you look at the the analogy
I was making about the battle map you
look at gamergate that institutional
power was behind that and we watched the
subversion of our institutions my
favorite is the Free Press an
organization I've known for a long time
called for the Banning of Alex Jones
so wait wait wait just a gosh darn
minute in 2011 they were like the free
press needs to stand and Independent
Media is important and then a few years
later they're like Alex Jones is evil
it's like aren't you guys the Free Press
why are you advocating for the removal
of a media well because it's fake news
I'm like what does the since when did
you take the position on what is allowed
to be news or not but here's my point
the right is now actively and angrily
pushing back in a way that's
unprecedented the way it's always been
viewed before is that the left is
pulling the entire country as hard as
possible leftward and the right was only
resisting a little bit
um or a better way to explain it is
Republicans are Democrats are having the
speed limit now the chain snapped the
Democrats have driven off the edge and
Republicans are stopping and saying no
more we're not moving this is the point
where we've actually seen active
resistance to the woke uh takeover
after a long period of time that's why
I'm optimistic on this because you know
I see the the only way the left wins is
if
people on the right stop and say you
know what I agree with the left and then
join them because what we're facing
right now is their cities are crumbling
and Narco tyranny doesn't work what
they're trying to do is destabilize
police departments destabilize cities in
an effort to take things over de Blasio
said during lockdowns that uh something
of the effect of buying up property as
prices collapse and then converting it
to public housing but but these these
policies only result in them losing
influence in power because despite what
they may hope with ESG and all that
stuff meritocracy still has a large grip
true capitalism still is a large grip if
you can't make money you can't get power
from it they can try manipulating the
Federal Reserve they can try and give
out loans and all that stuff but they
still need to be able to Garner
influence and for the first time
probably in Forever the right stuck a
stake in the ground and said we're not
moving now they're dealing with a
collapse in their own influence and
resistance at the same time I look at it
mathematically and say if every if I
were to step back from all of this and
just go into a tower and watch and I
started doing the math the math to me
looks like it will be a hard-fought
battle but the right will win either
through attrition or through
perseverance what can something the left
doesn't have what concerns me we're in
Austin right now I went around for a
walk earlier today and I saw like some
signs in yards like Beto O'Rourke trans
rights are humans rights and I'm like
you know what when I was in LA we would
have parties where I'd go to a party
there'd be a trans guy or girl uh
there'd be someone that barely spoke
English to be a communist there'd be a
Conservative Christian like and we'd all
get along and we would all talk politics
and we would all get along but I go to
this website I keep James Lindsay
brought this up beautiful trouble.org
it's a training website on how to do
direct violent action creatively and
it's like a pop-up get in trouble it
says so like how do you combat or resist
active attempts to organize destruction
active attempts to organize this
instructions but sorry this is my point
you should pull this website they're
destroying their own cities why am I
going to cry about it because they're my
cities too well not any longer dude get
out of cities too
what's the website economic Heartland
beautifultrouble.orging that we should
you gotta shine a light on this crap
well I mean maybe it doesn't say
anything violent on the website it's
real flowery but
and keep training keep in mind Creative
Energy injection and your direct action
keep in mind the problem it the problem
the real true heart of the problem is
not necessarily the street animals the
street animals are always an issue don't
get me wrong and they hurt people and
whatnot but the mob wasn't powerful back
when they were powerful because they
shot a bunch of people in the head the
mob was powerful back when they were
powerful because they owned the
positions of power they own the judges
and they own the cops and they own the
the they own the government positions I
disagree that's what the gate well it's
true that's what gave them their true
power that's why that's why any
organized crime in any area that really
takes hold the reason they can keep out
other organized crime when you think
they just go shoot them in it's because
he's just gonna have like the cartels in
Mexico half the times they use the cops
to kill you the cops will show right
right arrested take you out and shoot
you in the face the problem we have in
America is
they own the FBI they own the doj they
own the CIA the only NSA they all
they're from up on high from the
president on down oh wow you're a pro uh
you're a pro-life guy reading Bible
verses in an abortion clinic boom
abortion felony try to put him away
forever you're some uh I think it was a
transsexual guy today attacked the
Catholic church doj is recommending no
charges but we don't have the guys on
top and that's the issue and to it to a
certain degree I think it is but
confidence is the principle issue and
the reason why many judges won't uphold
the law is because they fear antifa now
you can say there's a component of this
and antifa will get away with crimes
therefore antifa's more confident in
committing crimes and getting away with
it but it all to me looks like one big
Mexican standoff
I see a bunch of people standing in a
crowd who don't like wokeness but will
not be the person to say anything
because they think everyone will then
turn to them
the average person in my opinion let's
look at that business in Portland kawava
that's shut down I'm willing to bet that
these people work at this Cafe in
downtown Portland would put flyers in
the window saying black lives matter and
you know in this house we believe
science is real and go Biden 2020. even
though they don't like the ideas even
though they despise the ideology they
would put those signs in their window
out of fear that if they don't antifa
will come and smash their Windows they
have confidence
that and it doesn't mean a good thing it
means they truly believe that if they
don't adhere their business will be
destroyed but this is my point their
business was already destroyed even even
their capitulation to the far left
extremists and their feigning of support
for them still resulted in their
destruction of their business that's why
I'm like look
confidence is everything if at any point
people no longer have confidence in law
enforcement law enforcement may as well
not exist you can see this in other
countries if you don't think a cop can
do anything to you you won't listen to
that cop
in the United States we do fear the
police because we are confident if we
break the law we will get arrested and
we will go to jail and the book will be
thrown at us now we're starting to see
in these big cities that ain't true so
crimes running rampant and people are
doing whatever they want which is
resulting in economic collapse the seats
of power may be beneficial but only so
far as human beings are actually working
on a system
that can maintain itself right let's
let's slow down all back up
when we talk about third fourth and
fifth generational Warfare the question
is
if you could take over a country without
firing a single bullet
would you do it right if you want to
take over country and there was a means
but by which you could do it without
firing a single bullet or engaging in
any violent action would you do it well
the answer is of course because violence
is expensive and resource heavy if there
was a cheaper and easier way to do
anything you'd do it so that's why we
see information Warfare
these people need power they want power
in order to have power people have to do
things that benefit them and Empower
them
so if they're a judge if they're in
charge of law enforcement in a city with
no people
they have nothing
those seats of power completely
meaningless if confidence in those
cities has shattered to simplify it even
a great to a greater degree
if there are a hundred people and one
person becomes the chief of police
so long as those people keep working and
paying taxes and they believe that chief
of police has power that chief police
can get those people to do whatever he
wants he can then Implement changes he
can put whatever flag he wants and those
people fear him but if it comes to a
point where no matter what happens these
people are failing and their businesses
are destroyed they're just going to say
the system doesn't exist and I'll give
you I'll give you another example of
where I think this is going and why I
think this the founding fathers talked
about the right of the presumption of
innocence
the rooted in the story of Sodom and
Gomorrah
the idea that it is better that 10
guilty persons Escape than one innocent
person suffer is not just about
protecting individuality it was about
protecting the system itself
if you have a society where everyone
believes that no matter what they do
whether they're good or bad they will be
punished one there's no incentive to be
good at all look I'm gonna go work my
job and be honest but those guys are
destroying everything they're stealing
everything and they're not getting
arrested what's the point of being good
I might as well join them but
if the system says if you were a good
person we will do everything in our
power to make sure the weight of
government is never pressed against you
you will have the presumption of
innocence then the the pressure is
created that says to a person be the
innocent one don't be the criminal and
the system will make sure you are safe
so now that they're creating cities and
institutions that punish people no
matter what they do they're actually
gutting and destroying their own their
own structures their own institutions
their own power base and that's why I
was saying so long as these cities and
places like Florida and Texas exist that
are turning redder or West Virginia
they can do whatever they want they're
knocking the legs out from their own
structures and we are building up hours
stronger and better than ever so I say
who cares let them do it I think of that
though San Francisco I see the homeless
is I keep hearing about how horrible it
is and part of me has this like
malicious grin on the inside where I'm
like good they deserved it then the
other part of me is like they do am I a
horrible human for feeling that way no
they do what's wrong with me that I
would would enjoy that or any Glee
you're supposed to you're actually let
me explain by you thinking that what you
just said right now that makes you a bad
person you know why because these people
voted for this stuff and I have a smile
on my face saying I'm so happy for you
that you got what you asked for you
should be very very happy that that
business in Portland that shut down I'm
happy for them I'm not far be it from me
to go tell these people what they should
vote for this is what they wanted they
got it and so I say I hope I hope you're
happy with what you voted for
congratulations the new mayor in Chicago
Brandon Johnson
they did a breakdown of the areas of
Chicago who voted for Brandon Johnson
and Brandon Johnson I mean people
thought Lori Lightfoot was was bad he's
so much worse by orders of magnitude
Chicago will be War as within a year
it's just it's going to he's dead yeah
exactly seriously Iraq he's that bad and
they they broke down the areas that
chose Brandon Johnson there was another
guy much more moderate it was a little
tougher on crime but they broke it down
and it was all the areas of Chicago that
are already most ravaged by rapes and
murders and violent crime every single
day those people flocked to the polls
and voted for Brandon Johnson so the
sympathy from this guy is gone I just
liked him I am excited for the people of
Chicago I I feel well like we are
blessed to live in a country where we
get the government we deserve and they
went out to the polls and they chose
Brandon Johnson and I'm very excited
that they are going to experience living
under Brandon Johnson and you know why
I'm excited about about that I'm excited
about that because as a father of two
sons the truth is the harsh truth of
life is you really learn through pain
that's where you learn I can tell you
all day long hey don't touch the griddle
the griddle's hot stay away from The
Griddle Don't Touch The Griddle the
griddle's hot the truth is like the old
saying goes you gotta walk up to it as a
kid and touch it and then it's oh my
goodness I'm never touching it again but
the people have not experienced enough
pain for their stupidity yet and the
greatest thing you can do for a stupid
person is allow that stupid person to
suffer under their stupidity because
it's the only chance a stupid person I
become smart yeah but I think I I
wouldn't take the approach you're taking
in the the outright uh gloating that you
think they'll suffer Oh They'll suffer
perhaps but my attitude is I'm so happy
for you that your voting worked
thank you have a nice day
this is why I'm gloating because I'm
tired of coddling Voters on the left and
the right and I ride the right about
this all the time you heard me do it
earlier when it comes to primaries you
whine about the there there's too much
cheating and there is cheating I admit
that and there's too much just and then
you sit at home and don't show up for a
primary vote you don't show up for City
Council vote and they vote for all of it
so stop you owned it you voted for it
and I feel the same way about the people
on the left you mentioned Portland
Chicago San Francisco wherever it is
over and over well I always vote
Democrat yes you've always been stupid
and now your stupidity is killing people
so clearly your stupidity has not heard
enough yet at some point in time I hope
it will so you'll wake up until that day
enjoy your hellhole but I don't even
here's my view right you go to someone
in Chicago and you say what you just
said you've accomplished nothing like oh
I know no no I know they're gonna have
to experience pain but I said nothing I
say is going to matter pain but what
will matter is
if you go to someone in Chicago and they
if someone I've had people from Chicago
come to me and talk to me about this
stuff and I simply say like I don't
understand the problem they'll be like
yeah there was like a shooting that
happened on my street it was crazy and
I'll be like okay I'm I'm I'm sorry I
don't understand like well it's just
crazy crime's gone nuts and I'll be like
I'm I'm confused are you unhappy about
that they're like yeah it's it's
horrible and I was like oh well because
you voted for it I thought you that's
what you wanted and they'll go I didn't
want this and I'd be like you were
arguing with me in November about how
you did I'm I'm gen I'm sorry I just
genuinely don't understand what you're
trying to accomplish oh we're saying the
same thing I just get there more
directly I ask them who'd you vote for I
don't can you believe this guy just got
shot here who'd you vote for last
election oh the Democrat congratulations
you voted for that but my point is your
approach
comes to them as an enemy instead of the
option you see what I mean yeah but my
Approach once you've done year after
year decade after decade after decade of
the same behavior and same behavior and
same behavior and same behavior burning
you burning you burning you burning you
burning you it's very clear that there's
no approach look the right is taking
every approach it the the there's no
approach that's going to convince you of
of anything else you're going to have to
experience pain the approach it doesn't
matter how I tell my son a different way
not to touch the griddle I can yell I
can be nice I can put a hand on his
shoulder he's gonna have to touch the
griddle and experience there's a
difference between someone understanding
the consequences of Elections and
touching a hot stove no there's not
there absolutely is Chicago's been under
Democrat rule for 100 years well maybe
Chicago was a bad example because that's
true but this is all cities the issue is
a politician steps up and says I can
tell you what the problem is and they
say finally someone different but they
don't understand that they're not going
to solve that problem by voting for the
same the same types of people
so they think they are not here I'll put
it this way you've got a griddle you've
got an electric stove top and a gas
stove top and they go oh geez that one's
hot I'll try this one oh man that was
hot too let me try that one and every
year a different type of cooking device
is placed before them that they don't
understand well the upside is once you
touch a hot glowing red piece of iron
you know that all those other glowing
red hot things you don't touch those
either I've never touched lava and I
won't because I did touch a stove one
time when I was little but this let's be
honest I don't think I don't think
they're gonna learn I mean I agree with
you that pain and suffering are a great
way to to kind of teach yourself and to
learn but and then sacrifice but that's
not what's happening here and and when I
look at Chicago when I look at New York
City I don't feel feel gleeful I feel
kind of sad because I see people stuck
in this endless horrible Loop and so
much human suffering that they're
bringing upon themselves how do you
solve that is is is a problem that I
think is is very difficult and I think
more complex than just oh I don't I
don't celebrate the condition of
America's cities America's cities are or
any Nation cities they're what goes on
your billboard I love New York City it's
one of my favorite places in the world I
love Chicago I I look at what's happened
to America's cities and I lament it but
I've gotten to the point where look I
can't help you you you very clearly
won't help yourself I can't help you all
I can do now is sit back and hope it
gets painful enough that you will one
day realize you're doing this to
yourself at some point in time I can
only drive the attic to rehab so many
times and then he's gonna have to hit
bottom and that's about
but I do want to add one last thing and
then maybe we'll we'll elaborate on this
in the members only show but uh did you
see when I overlaid the Chicago
electoral map with racial demographics
they don't they didn't vote for Brandon
Johnson because they're far left they
voted for Brandon Johnson probably
because of his race okay well that's
stupid too stop voting for People based
on skin color the white people did it
the Latinos did it I know the black
people did it the white liberal woman
did it the black people didn't know the
white liberal women voted for the black
candidate because white liberal women
have an out-group preference so you can
actually look at the regions the the
racial map in Chicago and see the
different neighborhoods based on race
and you can see that in white
neighborhoods it was the white
candidates and a little bit of Brandon
Johnson the far left candidate but in
the black neighborhoods the top
candidates were all black even if they
were some of the lower polling
candidates for the rest of the city well
I would change my voting behavior then
so I predicted Brandon Johnson would win
for one reason
white voters were mobilized to vote
because of the high crime but black
voters still voted for Lloyd Lightfoot
she didn't win because white voters
finally mobilized but in the north uh
northern part of the of Chicago where
there's universities these are younger
people they voted far left they voted
for Brandon Johnson
this resulted in a split vote which led
to a runoff between vallis and Johnson
and so my prediction was if every one of
these areas votes based on race combined
with the far left voting for The out
group and the far leftist Johnson will
win and sure enough that's what happened
but we're gonna go to Super Chat so if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com because we're gonna have
that members only show coming up for you
at about 10 10 p.m Eastern but let's uh
read your super chats for now
all right let's see what we got here
all right Matthew recap says I'd love it
if you could shout out the response
tweet I sent to Cornell W Brooks tweet
of the little girl reciting her school's
lockdown policy name one
uh
uh what's the what's the response tweet
I sent I'm not sure I know the one
uh let's read some more it looks like
we're having internet issues maybe I
don't know are we
it's been spotty for me just the Wi-Fi
the the ones that we're on right now
hasn't been the best but has the has the
stream Health like looked good it's been
fun for me all right well it is what it
is all right let's read some more
grinning Tiki says shout out to a drink
with crazy Channel supporting Iron Age
creators and winning culture conflict
very cool
all right let's see we got here
uh Tammy B best says Tim have you heard
of the representation study which the
YouTuber leather apron Club performed on
your show I'd be curious to hear your
opinion at nope uh what what is that
what is that referring to representation
study don't know what you're talking
about I used to have a band called The
Leather apron Club that's right Ben
Franklin's yeah in the Ben Franklin's
secret society their group they would
get together and they were all like uh
Masons they would wear leather aprons so
they called themselves a leather apron
Club Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim my
guy I agree let the cities crumble let
their families fear Rumble let their
souls stumble they deserve the reaping
of what they sow they get no empathy for
me no longer are we humble yeah I don't
want them to suffer but there's like you
said Jesse you can't just you can't feed
an addict you have to let them fall
actually actually I think I think people
should suffer but to like a certain
degree right I think oh yeah I don't
want anyone to die I don't know but
they're gonna but hold on hold on I'm
speaking philosophically The Human
Experience involves Joy pain sorrow
Elation Etc and so I think everyone
should experience the gamut of human
emotion I think it would be rather sad
actually to see a person who never
experienced any kind of hardship in fact
they'd create their own hardship so in
terms of a practical context I don't
want people in cities to go through
hardship because of their ignorance but
I do think in a general philosophical
sense wanting someone to suffer is not
necessarily the bad thing I'm being a
little bit potential I know what you
mean you want them to go through the
motions of learning to suffer to learn
happiness to learn right you know so
it's not so much like you this is what
you get I'm like well you know like
you're saying like you'll touch the
stove it will hurt and then one day
you'll say I shouldn't have done that
and maybe that's hopefully what we get
out of it
you know look at the human The Human
Experience but my my view is you know
simply put I don't care I don't live in
this place what is it this is a little
maybe you can answer this quickly what
are the characteristics of the people
that are creating crime in the cities
that people should watch out for when
they're going to the polls
well I don't know I'm not in the cities
yeah you know here's the thing whatever
you have one of these people it well
it's what Tim just said if you're going
to have every white woman vote for the
black candidate
if you can have every black person vote
for the black candidate then what are we
talking about here none of it matters if
we're going to vote based on on skin
color in cities then they're done that's
others do it if that and and you could
say well history or tradition okay well
whatever the reason the reasons don't
matter if you're gonna go vote for the
black candidate every time and they're
going to dig up a black communist to run
for office every time you're going to
get ruled by Communists and your city's
gonna be hell
all right let's read some more let's get
uh get another Super Chat here
chrome gear IRL says it makes sense to
me now why it was required for me to
listen to NPR on my Sociology class on
my local Community College back in 2003
never really cared for that class I'm
just taking it for GE
two a willy says I've been drinking Bud
Light for many years also I do drink it
so I can drink a lot of it everyone here
still agrees on many principles I'm two
cases deep on Lone Star since the ad
aired don't alienate your viewers
is uh but he's got to make sure his Lone
Star a a bush Anheuser-Busch brand yeah
I just learned Modelo is one too which
oh really that's awesome too yeah yup
yup Goose Island yeah and azerbush
bought them
all right let's see what we got here
we'll grab some more
Doug Rutledge says fun fact there's a
completely separate Budweiser brand from
the Czech Republic it is made in a town
that used to be called budweis they
often fight with American Budweiser over
the brand name
well isn't that a shame
now they're gonna have to change their
names associated with it right no that's
not us that's not us
Ryan F says stock not even down two
percent for the month smoke screen
the Scandal just happened last week why
would the the point is their stock
actually spiked over the past month they
were they were they were on a heater you
were buying that stock you were
celebrating then they went and pulled
this move and now you're probably going
why am I losing money and here's the
thing
people may see this and then be like I
better sell now because if this story is
not going away after two weeks you know
some people might think
it's you're going to lose money right
and that's what that's what ends up
happening in these panic stock Cycles
when the stock starts selling off people
say I better sell now before it's
worthless if I'm in at 100 bucks on you
know if I buy a Bitcoin at 30 grand and
the price is dropping I better sell it
27 before it hits a thousand and that
causes it to drop further and further
and further people offload look at the
trend what happened was on Monday it
dropped drastically at stock opening
because people over the weekend were
freaking out and then there was a
rebound where people were like hey the
stock's down buy as much as you can and
it jumped back up and then it just
plummeted dropped back down again and
other brands are going up people bought
yeah people buy back up a drop back down
again the trend is down on that on
Anheuser stock right now Eric Miller
says Nashville is the Beer Capital if
they just reject it there would be a
massive hit to Bud Light well look at uh
John Rich's Honky Tonk he says we're not
going to carry this stuff you know he
well he he didn't John Rich didn't come
out like Kid Rock with the machine gun
John Rich came out and just said hey
look man over the past week we've not
moved any of this product and I got to
consider if people aren't going to buy
it what am I going to do you know so his
attitude is probably more like hey look
I get it people are pissed about this
they're not buying it we're gonna end up
with a lot of garbage on our hands I'm
gonna buy it it's really simple I'll
just buy a different beer we'll sell
that instead I should clarify too it's
the trend of inbev that's down right now
Anheuser is just a company that in Bev
owns or that was right you need to look
at Bud yeah they could dump that
Anheuser-Busch uh brand name and just go
try and mask what they're doing but it's
in Bev that you want to watch out for
James garlic says you can take our NFL
you can take our children but when you
take our beer that's when we get mad
also Temple the reason you got hate for
the Mario movie review is because you
didn't understand the Deep lore and
Nintendo fans are Fierce lore nuts what
uh what of the Lord didn't I understand
though I'm not sure I understand you
said that Princess Peach was a badass
and that I was like well Super Mario
Brothers 2 she was and you're like yeah
but that was a dream and I think that
was a good argument I didn't see the
movie but if they made Peach about us
they made she has her own she has her
own video game that there's a bunch of
other issues well no spoilers man no
spoilers I haven't bitter the new one
yet yeah my bad also what are we doing
it's not Princess Peach it's Princess
Toadstool and then there's one scene
where she's specifically I'm joking
why what no it was Peach well you said
Princess Toadstool I don't know when
they changed it and they called Bowser
King Koopa but his name is Bowser he's
the king of the Koopas so basically this
is this one's really confusing to me oh
princesses we went and saw the Mario
movie and I wouldn't call it like the
wokest move I've ever seen I would just
call it like feminist cringe you know
what I mean oh don't tell me that but I
think but I think that reaction is why I
was I was gonna take the kids because I
heard it didn't have any of that crap
and this is the craziest thing to me
because Luke and I walked out of that
movie and Luke called started making fun
of it because Princess Peach is
Invincible she she okay let me put it
this way girl boss if you want no
spoilers I respect that Jesse but if you
want the spoiler I don't want spoilers
no no take your kids to the Lion's Den
okay all you need to do is take the kids
or not
I I Gotta Give You spoilers to help you
understand if that's the case
all right give them to me uh I'll keep
it light
there are people who think wopeness
includes movies where women are Mary
sues who are invincible and the men are
bumbling idiots I do I think I hate it
those are my least favorite movies
that's Mario okay so uh simply put Luigi
is an ancillary character Luigi is the
Damsel in Distress print uh Princess
Peach's storyline could have happened
without Mario in it at all uh
yeah so so
Mario's storyline is a one big accident
and Princess Peach's storyline is the
hero of her kingdom fighting Bowser and
saving the day of course and in the end
uh
I'll try to avoid being too spoilery let
me just put it this way
if they replaced Mario with
Jim Bob walking down the street the
story would have been exactly the same
Mario doesn't contribute in any way it's
very much like um
uh we talked about this with I think
it's like Indiana Jones you know like
they say that in the first Indiana Jones
if he wasn't in the movie the movie
would have happened the exact same way
because in the end the Nazis open the
the Ark of the Covenant and die anyway
and there's things like that but people
people uh uh it's the weirdest thing
when the movie trailers first came out a
bunch of people said it was woke girl
boss feminist cringe and I was like I
don't know I don't care and then I saw a
bunch of conservatives saying it's not
woke that's what I've seen that's why I
was going to see and they're like it
made a whole bunch of money for
rejecting wokeness and then I was like
I'm just confused by that because when
Ghostbusters 2016 came out the big
criticism was that all the women are
Mary Sue's they're all really smart and
capable and they develop this technology
and the men were all really stupid and
then when I went and saw Mario I was
like oh yeah it's like that you know
what I mean like Princess Peach is the
one who trains Mario Mario is incapable
of of of of doing anything no I I got it
you know the backstory stuff a thousand
times
to make him succeed so the drugs
basically oh I guess that's it's a movie
about drug drug use
I do love it
but I'll tell you this and I I will say
this unabashedly right now I made a
video about it it's a half an hour long
because I went and saw the movie
I believe that the the Rabid defense of
the movie so I got 70 thumbs up on the
video I made which is not normal for my
videos normal it's like 98 thumbs up 30
thumbs down and I have conservatives
arguing to me that it's not woke and I
said okay if the conservatives have
moved the peg to the point where the
traditional damsel and distress
character is actually the Kung Fu
heroine who is the one who actually
never gets hurt and already has the
abilities then the goal posts have
shifted from 2013 where we would have
called that feminist cringe and that
just means to me that the right is
losing
so a lot of people say look Princess
Peach can fight in Smash Brothers
Princess Peach is a playable character
in Mario 2 which is an OG game from the
80s super Princess Peach she has her own
video game she's a playable character
who fights in Mario RPG and Paper Mario
I get all of that I have absolutely no
problem whatsoever with Princess Peach
being a strong female character the only
thing I'm pointing out is Mario is a
goofy sidekick
oh he was always kind of a lumbering
fool that's the Mario he's just like
this dumb plumber from the Bronx
and like I think you play Mario RPG play
Mario RPG and Mario is a legend you walk
around like you're Mario you're the
greatest Jumper in the world think about
the first game because he and Peach
already have a backstory when the first
game begins but you don't know what it
is so maybe this movie is a prequel to
the first Super Mario bro and not only
that but like people are mad that I I'm
pretty sure Mario 2 is originally Doki
Doki Island it was awesome I know a lot
about Mario I don't know if people think
I don't maybe maybe I'm not the world's
expert on Mario whatever all I'm saying
is Luke and I walked out of that movie
without knowing anything about it both
being like what was that
oh the storyline sucked too I didn't
enjoy it so I have no problem with this
they didn't want a strong plot because
uh Miyamoto said we don't want to wade
into this and piss people off keep it
simple there were a bunch of nostalgia
references I think the movie's primary
audience was 35 year old men who have
kids and want to be nostalgic about
Mario and these video games and the
games they played and uh they probably
you know don't really care about the
feminist tropes or whatever or whatever
my point is simply that like
people are saying it's a traditional
hero's journey Tim and I'm like I mean
kind of but like Luke Skywalker is kind
of the dude who saves the day and is the
chosen one when I saw this movie it was
more like
you know I I'm a spoiler alert since
I'll say it again just because I've been
spoiling it but like when Mario
accidentally finds himself in this place
and Luigi accidentally finds himself in
this place there's already a war it's
already happening Bowser's motivation
has already been set it's completely
immaterial to anything having to do with
Mario and Luigi when Mario goes to
Princess Peach his presence there has no
meaning whatsoever on the conflict
that's already occurring in the Mario
Universe when when Bowser's Fortress
finally arrives to destroy the Mushroom
Kingdom Mario's not there and Princess
Peach is the one who confronts him
Princess Peach is the one who chooses to
surrender to him in which she gets
captured but it was all the ruse she
then you know like I don't want to spoil
too much master plan and then yeah it
was her master plan and then Mario look
at her no you are she's like making fun
of him yeah the one thing I will say was
anti-woke was when she said look how
small you small you are are you even
human and I was like wow that's pretty
little person phobic anyway anyway I
should read more Super chat instead of
complaining about Mario to be honest
yeah shout out my short Kings all right
let's see what got David Toronto says I
run a business and uh a b products
versus Miller was about 30 to 70 percent
for an Azure Bush this week we ordered
more Miller products it's deaf real and
drinking is a habit people will get used
to their new beer yeah
you can do that quickly too
yep
T-Rex Pet Shop says we are in small town
Idaho they're promoting all ages drag
here we have to stand up to these people
we can't let them do this to our kids
stop supporting woke pet stores give us
your money instead hear that's all I
care about yeah so uh where we're
opening our new business our new shop in
West Virginia they had an all ages drag
show
and the first reaction I had was when
looking at property I said I will not
set up in a town that does this then I
stopped and thought about it and said
actually I know this is exactly where we
need to set up because we're going to
put molon labe in the window we're going
to put America First in the window we're
going to put West Virginia best Virginia
in the window and then we are going to
create that cultural influence that will
push onto the other businesses and
simply put and realistically put the
power that we wield thanks to the
members that we have and the wealth that
we have will force a correction in this
town love it so when we are able to say
we can sink a million dollars into a a
project over one year in this town that
speaks to people and when they say all
that stuff does is like it's a weird
event why do we care about that
simply put we have the means to expand
this business buy more properties and
have tremendous influence over this town
in a positive way that is good for the
people who live there and pushes back on
the woke of garbage
thanks to all of you as members that's
that's the plan and then ultimately our
plan is to have 50 different coffee
shops all over the country where people
can hang out
well I like it yeah one day
imagine you walked into you saw you saw
a coffee shop you look on your phone you
type coffee cast Brew Coffee pops up and
you're like it's coffee it's fine you
walk in and what do you see TVs on the
walls Stephen Crowder playing
and then you're like I don't know
whatever and you go buy a coffee and
then you sit down and you're drinking
your coffee and then the next day the
place is if you have a fry Robert Barnes
Tim cast or Jesse Kelly
the idea is
regular people will come to buy coffee
but we will just make sure we are
exerting our cultural influence in these
spaces I like it
all right let's grab a couple more Super
chats
Beowulf says look up Proctor and Gamble
stock over the last year
what is it bad
I will look that up I'm assuming most of
it bad
Justin and uh and and peace says did
Stephen Crowder win versus the daily
Wire by just making mug Club his own and
what's your opinion on Brian Callan and
Nick depaolo being brought in to add
more content
Stephen Crowder definitely won he's
crushing it right now well I don't know
if they won I mean they're both doing
very well yeah they both won and uh
wonderful publicity stunt but I think um
my personal opinion is everyone would be
better off running their own brand
running their own website and that's
what the goal of uh you know the the
open sort of Technology yeah I was just
thinking about the open source project
you know that's uh the company that I
have is called inverted technology the
idea was to create an open source
package that anyone could install on a
website and have their own Subscription
Service it's kind of a bummer to me that
everyone still just decides to work for
someone else but I get it not everybody
has the wherewithal to run a company
it's certainly not easy right people
should be able to run their own business
that's employee one you I think that
that's how you do a lot of sense that's
how I've been doing it for forever and
then you can work your business with his
business and two businesses come
together rather than an employee and
we're unofficially like working together
and that's what we're doing with we are
change and Tim cash without even a
contract we don't need a contract we're
cryptographically split income we're
just Bros
just homies doing homemade things
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
grumpy bomber says what would you think
about this beer issue being similar to
Napoleon going too far and this would be
the long turning point that ends
Insanity I'm saying at the very least I
hope so yeah Napoleon uh said you know
let's go to Russia in winter
yeah well that don't work Hitler did
that too that's right they don't learn
and uh I think maybe that's what I was
saying like but the the woke people said
we've garnered enough cultural influence
to try and take beer and they were wrong
I hope
so we got to sustain this one
all right Tim Hardin says howdy fellow
Tim I run a non-profit in Texas that
scores State lawmakers on fiscal issues
everyone in the org is a big fan we will
be there Friday Ron Paul last night was
epic keep it up check us out Texans for
fiscal responsibility very cool very
cool very excited for Friday I looked at
Procter and Gamble stock it's just down
and then up there's nothing like notable
about it it just I'm not sure why that
was brought up
let's see
paracelsis says in Star Trek there was
the Eugenics Wars of the 21st century we
are fighting Eugenics Wars now
yeah I think versus plastic people
pointed that out
um you know based on the Star Trek shows
the new ones where they talk about this
stuff too
yeah I don't watch I don't watch those
uh nerd shows but but you're dead on
there's a deep deep depopulation agenda
happening right now that's right in your
face Diane Reynolds says Tim every time
we watch your daily video Bud Light is
the ad we need to skip through also Ian
needs to watch Peter zihan to learn
about China I love that guy and yeah I
was this is my concern about talking
about Bud Light is are we being
manipulated by the algorithm to promote
Bud Light and make them money in the
long run I think Tim your argument about
because not all press is good press so
boycotts are definitely a form of
negative press that can hinder a company
all right let's see
Grayson says the creator of Mario
literally said that he is meant to be an
average guy
and that's fine and I can respect that
but when I play Mario RPG one of the
greatest Mario games of all time he's
actually talked about as the greatest
jumper of all time legendary so strong
and when you play Mario 64 without any
power-ups Mario onlys his special hats
to fly and turn to metal he can punch in
Mario 64 he runs jumps punches kicks and
butt Stomps and he's a kitty and but
cute little kitty I'm fine with that
Tanooki Suit the raccoon Leaf these
things have always been a part of Mario
you never fired the the fire shots
though
and he's a feeling spoilers man
I'm ignoring you guys but he's a loser
in in in in Brooklyn with a failing
business oh Brooklyn I thought it was
Bronx he's Brooklyn Brooklyn
yeah I look I I I I I didn't hate the
movie I thought it was passable it
wasn't the greatest movie it was fun
Nostalgia it was I thought it was really
cool when uh you know Donkey Kong and
all that stuff I don't want to give out
spoilers I thoroughly enjoyed that I'm
just saying like why are people acting
like it's not woke like there's feminist
cringe in it you know people get really
mad about that
all right let's see what do we got
Joshua mosque says I do agree with your
theory that if we had 20 years that if
we had 20 years and conservatives had a
lot of children banks for change but if
you look at our world and compare it to
the Bible we are heading it to the end
of days we don't have 20 years no it's
the end of the story of the Bible not
the end of days it's the apocalypse
which is the great unveiling and that's
what's happening is the data is being
being revealed our personalities and our
desires are being revealed on a global
scale and there's the Communist thing
there's the all these different you know
says puts are up 100 is that true on bud
can we check that that'd be interesting
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and
become a member over at timcast.com by
heading to timcast.com and clicking join
us and then you can join the VIP chat
and check out the members only
uncensored show that will be live in
about 10 minutes so do that follow uh
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends you can follow us on
Instagram at timcast IRL you can follow
me personally everywhere at timcast
Jesse do you want to shout anything out
no uh Jesse Kelly show on every single
week night six to nine Eastern Monday
through Friday they podcasted after this
jokes I know you're all going to be
watching Tim cast anyway so just go
download it when you're done I do have
an anti-communist Manifesto book coming
out you can pre-order it
jessiekellybook.com other than that go
fight for your country take it back
Jesse thank you so much for coming on
that was great really appreciate it my
website is lucanfiltered.com 3 30 P.M
tomorrow Austin real in life Meetup uh
I'm gonna be giving out pickles there's
gonna be surprise guests I'm going to be
putting the address six hours before the
Meetup on lukeunfiltered.com one of many
perks available lookenfilter.com see you
there tomorrow Jesse Kelly DC on Twitter
always a pleasure my man Jesse Kelly DC
on Twitter appreciate you in I just had
a thought maybe the reason the Bible
story is coming to a close in these days
this is the apocalypse in the end of the
Bible story is because another story is
about to begin so it'll probably look
back and see us as part of that story
you're included
bye I'll take it
all right everybody oh wait sir
yeah I'm here what's up guys how are you
uh asters.com if you want to follow me
on Twitter
right on everybody we will see you all
over at timcast.com in about 10 minutes
thanks for hanging out